hi there today we're looking at
discovering symbolic models from deep
learning with inductive biases by miles
Cranmer Alvaro Sanchez Gonzalez peter
pettalia ruiz you Cal Cranmer David
Spergel and Shirley ho so this paper on
a high level it uses graph neural
networks to fit a data set of
observations of a physical system and
then it uses symbolic regression in
order to parse out in equations symbolic
equations from the graph neural network
and the symbolic equations that will are
found such they describe the physical
system and they do find they do recover
some known equations and they do find a
new one in the field of cosmology so
we'll go through how they do it what
these two steps are and why this might
work better than previous approaches so
yeah join me if you like content like
this as always feel free to share it
subscribe if you haven't if you want
more content like this and tell me what
you think in the comments all right so
they claim we develop a general approach
to this still symbolic representation of
a learned deep model by introducing
strong inductive biases and this it
doesn't really it doesn't really say a
whole lot but I think the the abstract
doesn't say a whole lot so let me give
you an example if you have three
different let's say planets or stars
right this is a this three body problem
is a unsolved problem I think still so
if you have these three stars and you
just let the simulation run they have
gravity they attract each other right so
they are going to move around somehow so
this one's gonna move here this one's
gonna move like this this one's gonna
move like this and then it turns around
and this one turns around and and so on
so there is a fairly complex motions in
already three different things that are
somehow in a physical system together
this is a bigger problem than just
stars so you have these systems for
example when these are atoms and there
is like an electromagnetic force between
them or the strong force there can be
these can be things where Springs are
attached to them and so on
so our goal is to derive equations that
govern this behavior right in the case
of gravity we know that these objects
sort of pull on each other with the with
the force proportional to something like
the mass of the first times the mass of
the second divided by the radius that
they are a part squared something like
this
times like this gravitational constant
that's we know the equation that governs
these interactions we don't know the
symbolic solution to the whole problem
but we know the equation that governs
the interaction right now imagine if we
didn't know the equation what do we have
to do well what did Newton do ultimately
he sat down and just came up with an
equation that seemed ok to him and then
found out that the equation actually
does predict very accurately the how the
things move so we're going to try to
replicate that process in a in an AI
system the process of coming up with an
equation that governs this behavior so
what we have is a dataset as I said we
let this stuff run so we let it run for
one time step and then this is here
maybe this is here and this is here ok
and then we let it run for the next time
step this goes here this goes here this
goes here and so on so that will give us
basically it will give us frame by frame
how this system evolves frame by frame
and that will give us a dataset so this
right here if we let it run and maybe we
restarted a couple of times with
different initializations we let it run
we get a data set so now we have a data
set right so our goal is to be to take
that data set and come up with an
equation like m1 m2 divided by r-squared
that governs this behavior
now previous approaches have resorted to
symbolic regression I think they they
call this and that is basically it's
pretty simple namely what you do is you
simply provide the system with a bunch
of options
you tell it I have a list and the list
can include the mass of the first it can
encode the mass of the second and can
include the X and the y position of the
things it can include the Delta X and
Delta Y which basically means the speed
of the objects and it can include any
constant a and B that you want it can
include the symbols plus minus division
multiplication Square may be exponential
function and so on so you give it a
bunch of options of what it could
potentially use in an equation and then
you simply let it make equations and you
see how well these equations describe
the data set and the way you do that is
you can do it naively by just searching
and trying out or you can be a little
bit smarter about it and use like
evolutionary methods so you start with
like some equations like this you okay
I'm gonna X plus Delta X minus a squared
okay you see how that how that describes
the data set you'll find not very well
and then you go on and you say okay
maybe I'll make it like a small mutation
I'm you take this to a minus and so on
and if you do this with an entire
population as is common in these
evolutionary methods you'll you you end
up with something better at the end now
this works until a point
so whenever the the space of things to
explore like this one here gets larger
and it doesn't have to be super large to
already exhaust the capabilities of
these methods so these methods are very
limited in the space they can search and
have proven not really effective so far
for this type of problem this paper
right here goes a different
route it uses graph neural networks in
order to describe the dataset so in
between this step of collecting a data
set and making the equation it fits
another step so it says in between here
we fit another step and that other step
is going to be we have a graph neural
network and you don't know yet you don't
have to know yet what that exactly is
but it's technique it's like a type of
neural network and we're going to have
that neural network learn the data set
now as you know from neural networks
they can't do symbolic regression they
can't give you an equation they can
simply predict numbers so what the
network will do is it will simply
predict like the motions or the
accelerations whatever you're interested
in it will predict those things as
numbers not as equations as just you can
plug in this situation right here and it
will tell you how the things will move
okay neural networks are pretty good at
that and once you have a graph neural
network that can describe the system in
a numeric fashion then you parse out the
equations from this graph neural network
and we're gonna go over why that is
going to be much much easier than
parsing out the equations directly from
the physical system it's going to be
because you engineer the graph will
network in a way that makes it very
congruent with physical reality that
makes it very adapt to parse out
equations like this that makes the job
of this evolutionary method much easier
all right so that's the that's basically
the the two-step process here first step
is to numerically regress a neural
network to describe the system and then
second step is going to be from that
neural network parse out the equations
so we have to talk about graph neural
networks so here you see the entire
process as they describe it so they have
this data set right here of observations
of these physical systems
this is like it's like you know any data
set that you have in machine learning
they predicted the dynamics which means
in a numeric fashion with a graph a
neural network and then from the graph
neural network they extract the symbolic
equation as you can see right here and
this here is going to be the equation
that they figure out that was previously
unknown they even say it unknown dark
matter over density equation cool so we
have to talk about graph neural networks
we haven't really done this on this
channel so far and I'm not the like a
big expert on graph neural networks but
in they come in all shapes and forms in
this particular paper they use what they
call a type of interaction network
that's called a graph network so the
graph network is something different
than graph neural network I think graph
network is a type of graph neural
network and specifically here they use a
network that so a graph neural network
has these things called vertices and
then it has edges and edges connect
vertices like in a graph now we're going
to build this graph neural network such
that the number of vertices is exactly
equal to the number of particles in our
system so in this paper they consider
systems with I believe four or eight
particles that's already a lot for if
you want to derive equations and things
but of course the physical world is made
of many more particles in any case they
consider four let's say four particles
right here so what they're going to do
they're going to build a graph neural
network that has four vertices one for
each of the particles and in a graph
neural network every vertex can have
properties so the properties of each
vertex here are going to be the
properties of that particle that means
the x coordinate for example the y
coordinate and we're going to let's say
we're in two dimensions right it's a two
dimensional problem the x coordinate the
y coordinate the Delta X the Delta Y the
the I don't know what else what else can
we put here there's a lot of stuff that
we can put the other charge right so all
of these things are properties of the
vertex then the other component of a
graph are of course the edges so the
edges connect each to of all of the so
each edge connects to vertices like this
and in this particular type of graph
network we're going to consider graphs
where all the particles are connected to
all the other particles like this so
it's not like a sparse it's not a sparse
graph except I think in the cosmology
example here you can see that always
there is a node that's connected to all
its neighbors but in the Newtonian
dynamics graph networks you can see
right here everything is connected to
every thing like this okay and why why
does that represent a physical system
really well so the reason is going to be
the following what we're going to try to
do is we're going to try to say that in
physical systems if I want to for
example consider this node up here and
consider how it is pulled by gravity by
the other nodes it's going to be pulled
in this direction a little bit because
of this particle right here it's going
to be pulled in this direction a little
bit because of that one and in this
direction because of that one now note
that these three things are independent
so if I want to describe the total force
of gravity I can do so as a sum over I
equals 1 2 1 2 3 of the force that the
particle I pulls so if this is this is J
right here how I pulls on J right this
is an independent sum across all of the
all of the neighbors of that particle
now you might say wait a minute that's
it's not independent because it's it's
being you know it's not being strictly
pulled in this direction
also pulled in this direction yes but
the with independent we mean that the
force this force right here is only
dependent on this particle and the force
diagonal is only dependent on that
particle there is no part of the
particle up here that modulates this
force right here right so you can
calculate the total force as an
independent sum across the individual
forces and that's the simplification
here and that's a part they claim why so
current approaches that directly try to
go about finding an equation using
evolutionary methods from the data set
itself don't really work because these
space is just too high of equations but
this right here this is a massive
constraint and it's lucky first of all
that physical systems they say most
physical systems actually obey that
constraint most physical systems can be
described as an independent sum over
contributions of interactions between
just two things right so we simply can
sum over interactions between two things
and that's and that's way simpler than
considering everything at once
and second of all it's lucky because
these graph networks describe exactly
this so each edge in the graph network
is coincidentally connecting two things
right and not more so the edges they
don't know about each other no edge
knows about the other edge they only
consider whatever particles are at their
respective ends and that is exactly the
same as this physical constraint on the
physical system and that's why the graph
networks are so adapted or are so useful
in describing these systems so how does
a graph network like this do anything
basically so for that you have to
consider the task if we want to describe
a system like this a task in that demo
if you frame it in a machine-learning
way
could be I'm gonna give you these
particles right here okay here it's five
five particles I'm gonna give you for
each one I'm gonna give you all its
features like the X the Y the speed
currently and the mass and you're going
to tell me what the acceleration is in
the next frame okay so like this like
this like this okay considering all you
know all the interactions between the
particles just tell me where does it go
in the very next time frame that that
sounds like a machine learning problem
right and the graph neural network can
be made to predict this so what we want
is for each vertex here an output of a
number or a vector the acceleration so
we want to compute an output for each
vertex how do we do this in a graph
neural network there are three or in
this particular type there are three
steps we said each vertex and we're just
going to do it for one vertex let's say
the one on the bottom right let's say
each vertex has these properties like
these X Y and so on so first what we do
is we go over the edges so for each edge
in parallel and independent from each
other let's consider this edge right
here what we'll do is we take the nodes
that are attached to it and we combine
their features and we combine them so X
Y this also has X Y so we want to
combine these two we want to compute the
edge right here now in a physical system
what does the edge represent the edge
represents the force between the two
particles right and that's a fairly
complex equation it's not like we can
just add the features or something like
this so the edge here already needs to
compute some sort of nonlinear
complicated function and we know how to
compute nonlinear complicated functions
with neural networks
we're in deep learning right here
so the the edge here is going to compute
what's called this edge function and
this edge function takes in two vertices
v1 and v2 right here if this isn't maybe
this is v2 this is v1 it takes in the
features these features of the two
vertices and it will compute a so-called
edge message I think they call this ek
for the edge K it will compute an edge
message and this is supposed to
represent the force that pulls between
these two particles and we're going to
approximate this function right here
using a neural network since we don't
know the equation yet right we assume we
don't know the gravitational equation
but we can learn it right because we
have data so we take this and we simply
make it into a neural network so the
features go in here both we can you know
concatenate them and then out comes this
edge message now this edge message here
is simply going to be a vector a
numerical vector describing some
intermediate hidden state right that is
going to describe the force but for now
it's just describing intermediate hidden
State okay so we do this for each edge
so each edge has going to be maybe this
is e1 this is e2 e3 e4 each edge in
parallel is going to aggregate
information of its endpoints into that
edge and then that's step one so step
one compute the edge messages step two
is going to be to compute the vertex
messages or the vertex outputs so we
said we're not actually interested in
the edges we're interested that each
vertex ends up with an acceleration with
an output so how we're going to do this
so consider again our graph if we want
to compute the output for this node
right here what we'll do is we'll simply
aggregate all of the edges all of the
edge messages that connect to that
vertex so we've computed previously the
edge messages by integrating the
information from all
of the net from all of the attached end
points now we're going to go backwards
and distribute the information from the
edges back to the vertices that are
attached and you can see already by this
two-step process it's kind of a message
passing process if you've ever studied
graphical models the these this means
that in the two-step process this vertex
here aggregates information from the
other vertices right via these edges so
in this case this vertex here is going
to take in all the edge messages right
here and it is going to aggregate all
these edge messages in a function that
computes the acceleration so that our
estimate of the acceleration is going to
be a function let's call that new of the
edges that are attached to it so e1 e2
and e3 and here is where we going to
make our next physical assumption namely
the one we said before that the the way
that these edges the way that they
influence the vertex is going to be in a
form of an independent sum so the
simplification means that this function
should somehow be not of the edges but
of the sum of the edges right some of a
I okay so this sum here this is the the
simplification that we make to make it
in accordance with the physical system
we could do with this graph Network we
could do any sort of complicated thing
right here right we could put a
transformer on these things and like
compute twelve layers of interaction
effects between these edges we're not
going to do that we're simply going to
sum them up and then come up and then
you know run down those through a
function so we'll sum them up and of
course this function right here is still
going to be a complex function because
just because you
some up the forces you don't have the
acceleration yet so you know as you know
that force is mass times acceleration
that means acceleration is equal to
force divided by mass so this here is
going to be this sum over the edges I
guess yes so you still need to divide it
by force and technically you it still
can do much more complicated things
right here we still we only say that the
edges should only come in in in form of
a sum so of course we're going to say
that this function right here since it
can be any complicated function of its
input it should also be a neural network
so we're going to take that sum of the
edge messages and we're going to put
that into a second neural network and
then out comes our estimate of the
acceleration and now that we can use
together from the data set we know the
true acceleration right since we have a
data set we have the observations and
the labels the labels are the true
accelerations of that system that we
observed then we can compute a loss
function right here and if you followed
so far everything we've done so far is
differentiable so from this loss
function that compares the output of the
neural network for that vertex to the
true acceleration that we observed in
the data set we can back propagate
through this neural network that
computes the vertex function we can back
prop through the sum here to the edge
messages and we can back prop through
the edge messages to that neural network
that computed the edge messages from
those features so everything is
differentiable by having that loss at
the end we can train this neural network
end-to-end to from the observation right
here predict the numerical acceleration
of the system right here okay it was a
fairly lengthy way but
it's important that you kind of
understand what's happening so you built
the graph network according to the
physical system in the graph network
there are two kinds of things first
there are deterministic things like
we're always going to aggregate in a sum
and then there are things that you learn
namely there are two neural networks the
first one computes the edge messages
from the features of the vertices and
the second one computes the output of
each vertex according to the to the sum
of the edge messages that are attached
to that vertex now you can say wait a
minute there are more than just two
neural networks like each edge here has
a neural network technically right this
edge has a neural network this edge has
a neural network and each vertex has a
neural network but in this case these
neural networks are shared so the neural
network that computes the edge message
for that edge is the same as the neural
for any of the edges you can think of it
like weight sharing or you can think
that it is actually the same neural
network it's equivalent right and the
same for the vertices there is only one
neural network that in the same fashion
computes the the output for each vertex
of course the incoming edge messages are
going to be different and that's why you
have different outputs but the neural
network itself is the same okay
so we have a system that can describe
this data set of physical observations
really well it's this graph neural
network right so we train this end to
end and here is a little bit of an
analogy where they say this this is how
you can analogy like analogize the
neural network with a physical system so
what are the analogies here the nodes in
the graph network correspond to the
particles in Newtonian mechanics pairs
of nodes correspond to two interacting
particles the edge model is the force
between two particles then the pooling
operation which is the summing up of the
edge messages right that we found so
important as a simplification this is
the sum into the net force that is
really given in the physical system so
independent sum of so sorry sum of
independent forces without interaction
effects then concatenate with node I
guess this I left this out but whenever
you compute whenever you compute the
vertex properties right here I guess
what you want to do is not only input
the edge messages but you know each
vertex has these features that we said
and these could also be fairly important
it's like you technically have that
information in the edge messages because
it started out from this but you can
also just input that again into this
neural network together with the edge
properties and that will just make its
job a bit easier since for example right
here we have to divide by the mass in
this function and it's just easier if
you provide that mass as a as the
property so that's a little detail I
left out before so they you concatenate
the edge mess the aggregated edge
messages with the node then you compute
the node model which in this case is the
computation is simply the you take this
sum right here and you divide it by the
mass and then optionally you can update
the nodes which is compute the next time
so which we don't do right here because
we simply want to output the
acceleration I guess I mean I mean it
should be equivalent to output the next
time step and then compare compare with
the data set what the next time step was
in any case you have to have some kind
of loss function and here you can see
all the black squares right here are
going to be neural networks so now we
have learned a graph network that can
describe a system how do we make this
into an equation and again here our our
physical reality comes in
that these of the like the independence
assumptions of these realities comes in
because in physics you know the the
acceleration here is going to be a
function of the sum and so on what we
need to do is we don't need to develop
an equation for the entire system right
what we need to do is simply we need to
develop an equation for each vertex so
each vertex we need to have an equation
acceleration equals something and that
something should include some of the
edges and then the edges again should be
something right
so we technically as we had to neural
networks we technically need to symbolic
equations one that represents that first
neural network that computes the edge
functions and one that represents that
second neural network that aggregates
the at the sum of the edge functions or
that computes the output from the sum of
the edge functions and that you know
it's it's an exact correspondence so
what we need to do is we need to take
that first neural network up here and do
symbolic regression on that and the
second neural network do symbolic
regression on that so what does it mean
to do symbolic regression it it
basically means that we want to find the
symbolic equation that describes the
neural network the best right and we do
that in the exact same fashion as we
started right here so we give it a bunch
of these options and then we let the
system describe the neural network as
best as possible the way we do that
again is we try out equations and if
they just if they get a low error right
weak so we let the neural network run on
the data set and we let this run on the
data set if it outputs the same thing it
describes the neural network well and we
can iterate that until we find a good
equation so the difference here is that
we don't need to find an equation that
covers the whole system we just need to
find two equations one governing the
edge model and one governing the
texe model and that's way way easier
than the whole system and by finding
those two equations we and our given our
physical assumptions we can now find the
equation to the whole system by simply
composing them alright so that's the
entire system if I've told you the
entire paper right here without actually
going into into the paper let's just
skim the paper a bit to see that they
actually tell us the same thing so yeah
so the graph networks they say our ideal
candidate for our approach due to their
inductive biases shared by many physics
problems hey they're equivalent under
particle permutations we they are
differentiable end-to-end and can be
trained efficiently using gradient
descent and see they make use of three
separate and interpretable internal
functions to edge the node and the
global model now the global model here
isn't really used in the cases we're
going to look at so it's just going to
be two different neural networks which
are targets for the symbolic regression
graph network can also be embedded with
additional symmetries as in 2324 but we
don't implement these okay and then they
say symbolic regression so they use this
Eureka package to perform symbolic
regressions and fit compact closed form
analytical expressions to these neural
networks Eureka works by using a genetic
algorithm to combine algebraic
expression stochastically the technique
is analogous to natural selection where
the fitness of each expression is
defined in terms of simplicity and
accuracy the operations considered in
the fitting process are plus minus times
though if as well as real constants all
right so if we look at the examples they
have three different examples first of
all they have Newtonian dynamics which
is for example this gravitational force
we looked at they have Hamiltonian
dynamics which describes the same
systems but
in a different way in terms of the
Hamiltonian and I don't want to go into
this too much because I think the
Newtonian dynamics already demonstrate
really well what the system can do and
then they have Dark Matter halos for
cosmology which is a problem where you
have universe simulators and you try to
predict where the dark matter is
depending on where other dark matter is
and they actually that's where they find
a new unknown equation okay here is the
system in a nutshell now there is this
is the path that you know you have the
data set you learn a graph network and
then you get out an equation right but
in between there is now you can put even
more constraints to make the network
really learn a physical equation so we
said you're going to compute these edge
functions right here and the output of
the edge functions is going to be this
edge message which is just going to be a
vector of some sort and that vector can
be pretty large you know this is a
hidden dimension that you can choose as
an implementer all you need to make sure
is that the output of the vertex is the
same dimension as you know what your
output should be everything internal you
can choose now we know that for example
in a 2d system the the actual
informational content of that edge
message should be two-dimensional right
if this really describes the force in
two dimensions it it should be
two-dimensional there's really no reason
why it should have a higher dimension
since all the relevant information can
be described in two dimensions so one
thing you can do is you can simply say
alright I will choose the hidden
dimension to be two and therefore I will
force my neural network to just use two
dimensions this however they noticed
doesn't work super well I think it works
but not that well they call this the
bottleneck model and the reason why it
doesn't
works super well is that if you have
like this constraint of neural networks
they don't turn to they don't tend to
learn very well and that's what they
hypothesized in the paper as well they
don't tend to really come you know be
good friends with the fact that they
only have two floating-point numbers to
learn anything and this is probably more
a property of the optimization procedure
than the problem itself the property of
you know us training graph neural
networks with SGD so what they do
instead is they put an l1 penalty on
these edge messages so they say we apply
l1 regularization and what that will do
is that will induce sparsity in whatever
you apply it to so l1 regularization
simply means that you constrain so the
edge message if you take the absolute
value in each entry and the sum of that
that should be small so you can just add
this to the loss function and that will
induce sparsity in these edge messages
and so now the network still has these
whatever 100 latent dimensions but it is
encouraged to use as few as possible
that means it can use a lot during the
beginning when it's really benefits from
the lot of dimensions when it learns the
system but then as it gets better and
better it might shift a lot of the
information into very very few
dimensions okay
so once we do if we do that we can then
run a check right if it is really the
case that this graph network has learned
the physical dynamics of the system then
the top we can simply look at the top
two dimensions and we stored by a
largest standard deviation so whichever
two dimensions are the least sparse
right have the largest standard
deviation we can look at those two and
we say well even though we didn't
constrain the model those two should
describe our force pretty well and since
in Newtonian dynamics we know what the
force is so this is
we know what the force is we can simply
check whether or not that holds we can
check whether we can read out the force
from these two components and here it's
made such that you you can't guarantee
that the force is you know this force
right here is actually so there are many
ways to state a physical equation
because there are many symmetries in
physics and we cannot really make the
neural network describe the equation
exactly as humans would because there
are infinite amount of equivalent
formulations but there in this case
they're all covered by rotations of each
other and that means in these graphs if
you have these message elements right
here and the linear combination of
forces right here a linear relationship
means basically that the information is
there whereas a nonlinear relationship
would mean that these numbers don't
really encode the force as is and here
you can pretty clearly see that the
linear relationship is given and that
means that these first two dimensions
right here really encode the force in
the way that we know the equation is so
that's when we know the equation right
when we know the equation we can simply
say okay
does this fit and when we don't know the
equation we can use this symbolic
regression and what turns out is exactly
this thing right here
now you might you might object that is
isn't really that force right here but
as I said there are many many symmetries
so for example this this R hat right
here I believe and this is I've I'm not
a big physics person this R hat I think
this is the vector of the Delta X Delta
Y right so Delta X Delta Y is in this R
hat so we already see that Delta X and
Delta Y here this already looks like
some sort of this already looks okay
no actually if we go down it gets even
clearer so here they have the outputs of
that yes all right so in this first case
this is the the same example right here
so they say you in this spring example
so this is a system where the particles
are connected by Springs and we do l1
regularization what we expect is this
equation this is we know that this
equation holds in this spring system and
what the neural network combined with
the symbolic regression gives us is this
equation so right here you can see there
is this Delta vector and its product
it's an inner product a dot product with
this a which is a numerical constants
and you can see that there is this form
of product with numerical constants what
you can also see so for example here the
Delta Y here is one point three six and
one point three seven that's well you
know the same number and here it's point
six point six okay but here you see for
example R minus one and here it's
something like this - something divided
by R doesn't seem the same but again due
to the due to the symmetries you can if
you take this and you simply divide
everything by r you'll end up with this
vector right here a times Delta X Delta
Y times 1 over R no times 1 minus 1 over
R plus B right and now you can see it
already looks very much similar and it's
only off by like it's only a
transformation away from what you want
so that's why I said you can describe
these equations in many different sort
of equivalent ways we can't ask the
neural network to really figure out you
know the exact one we want as long as it
figures out a 1 that is equivalent we're
happy and we're I guess we're pretty
happy here
so also in this case right here you can
see that it correctly predicts this
relationship that it should be divided
by r to the third power and there is a
Delta X Delta Y Delta Z if you simply
consider so Delta Z here I guess is as
simply a factor of zero and it even has
this discontinuous problem where the
force breaks after a certain while it
can even parse out this if condition
right here so that's that's fairly cool
right that it to me that that is pretty
pretty cool result that you can actually
parse out these equations with just
these graph networks and then the
symbolic regression so they do the same
thing for this cosmology example where
they have these simulators of the
universe and they let them run and these
kind of distribute this dark matter and
I guess your task is if I give you a
bunch of these points right here tell me
where the other dark matter is something
like I don't understand this but in
essence it is the same kind of problem
right you want to figure out the dark
matter properties from the surrounding
dark matter or properties of other
things and again here
you can see pretty well that this is the
equation they get out so the equation
they get out is going to be a sum right
here over so here the output for node I
is going to be a sum over all the other
nodes J and then some function of that
sum so this right here is the equation
that came out of our edge model of our
edge narrow network and this here that
includes this one it was the equation
that came out of our vertex model as you
know the same here in this spring law
this came out of our edge model this
came out of our vert
model again this rests on the fact that
physical systems can actually be
described often as these sums of
independent interactions and that's why
all of this works so they do give very
very detailed instructions on how they
did everything I think the most unclear
things in this paper are the physics
things that are assumed sort of that you
know I don't I didn't yeah but other
than that it's pretty straightforward
their appendix is also pretty detailed
in how they do all the representations
and so on they have different
formulations other than this l1
regularization as I said if bottleneck
they have like a KL formulation they
really describe how the graph neural
network works here and so on so all in
all I enjoyed reading this paper here is
a bunch of examples of these particle
systems and yeah and here is a bunch of
examples of where you'd have a linear
relationship that where you can say oh
look this really describes that force or
a nonlinear relationship where you can
make the claim this doesn't really
describe the force well because it's not
a linear relationship indicates that
what the network found is a rotation of
what you really want and that's good
because it's equivalent nonlinear
basically means that you can't really it
it doesn't really describe what you want
really well yeah and I'm gonna leave you
with that
I absolutely invite you to check out the
code and the video they made about it
and I'll see you next time bye bye